the red
of raspberries there's over 33 virus and
virus like diseases reported on brambles
worldwide and over 15 in North America
but fortunately only a few are common in
eastern North America in this
presentation I'll go over the important
features about virus diseases and
discuss the virus diseases that I have
seen in Ontario really just a few I'll
provide information on how to confirm a
suspected virus disease and I'll end
with information on how to control or
really prevent virus diseases on your
farm so first of all what is a virus
while the virus is a microbe that can
cause disease in this case plant disease
now some viruses affect human health but
it's important to know that the viruses
that affect plants do not infect humans
viruses are quite different from the
fungal pathogens that cause many of the
bramble diseases we know first of all
viruses are much smaller they can only
be seen with an electron microscope and
they're really just protein particles
not even cells so they require a living
host and a cell in order to grow and to
multiply viruses can move systemically
in a plant so unfortunately once
infected the whole plant and all the
plant parts could carry virus particles
unlike other plant pathogens there are
no chemical controls for virus diseases
now because viruses live and multiply
inside plant cells they disrupt plant
cell processes and this can cause many
many different types of symptoms and the
the type of symptom that's expressed by
viruses depends not only on the virus
but it can depend on the time of year
the variety infect it and the number of
viruses present in the plant so these
symptoms include things like crumbly
fruit or yellowing or spotting of the
tissue leaf curl and low plant vigor
virus diseases are often named after the
symptoms that they caused for example
raspberry bushy dwarf virus is one of
the viruses we'll be talking about today
one thing about virus disease is the
symptoms show up
best in ten to show up best in cooler
weather especially in the spring and on
newer growth and the symptoms can
disappear after a while but even if the
symptoms on an infected plant go away
the plant is still infected with virus
and can still spread viruses to other
plants sometimes infected plants show no
symptoms at all and when this is the
case we say that the virus is latent and
for example virus symptoms are often
latent on wild or alternate hosts for
the virus disease this is one of the
most serious symptoms that virus
diseases can cause in raspberries and we
call this crumbly fruit or crumbly berry
another symptom is leaf model or or leaf
yellowing and you can see here the
irregular pattern of yellow and green
it's not too consistent it's not quite
typical of herbicide injury and this is
another symptom of viruses a very
unusual pattern of yellowing that's
associated with a virus disease the
pattern again is very inconsistent and
it's very variable in the leaf and this
symptom can come and go and is more
commonly seen in the initial stages of
infection
now this symptom of virus disease is
known as vein clearing it looks a lot
like herbicide injury but this is a
raspberry play in my garden these
symptoms show up year after year in the
spring and then they fade away and
disappear I'm pretty sure it's a virus
disease because I've never used
herbicides in my garden and also the
fruit from these plants is very very
crumbly now the last thing I need to
define before I get more specific about
raspberry virus diseases is what is a
vector viruses do not multiply outside
of the plants that they live in
and unlike fungal diseases they don't
produce spores that are carried in the
wind or splashed by rain and fires any
diseases need help to move around and
they need a wound to enter the plants
and the agent that spreads a virus
disease is what we call the vector some
virus diseases are spread by insects
most commonly aphids and leaf hoppers or
other pests with piercing sucking
mouthparts some viruses are spread by
pollen or seed and these are very
difficult to control and other viruses
can be spread by mechanical transmission
that takes place when there's grafting
or budding done on the plant and there
are are nematodes particularly the
dagger nematode that can spread viruses
from plant to plant now raspberry virus
diseases are generally classified by the
type of vector that spreads them and so
today I'm going to talk about these
three raspberry virus diseases raspberry
mosaic and leaf curl which are spread by
aphids the tomato ringspot virus which
is spread by dagger nematodes and the
raspberry bush ador virus that's spread
by pollen so to start with the the aphid
borne viruses there are two a food borne
viruses which seemed to occur in
northeastern america these virus
diseases are really important in the
Pacific Northwest where they grow a lot
of raspberries and we're a fad
populations tend to be higher but the
raspberry mosaic virus is also found in
the Northeast and but personally I've
never seen
the leaf curl virus these viruses are
vectored by a Fitz particularly the
large raspberry aphid which is common in
the Northeast but not abundant and the
small raspberry feed which hasn't
actually been reported in Ontario the
only host for both the aphids and these
virus diseases are raspberries and this
fact is very important when it comes to
controlling this virus disease or aphid
borne viruses now raspberry mosaic virus
is really a complex of different virus
diseases but it's all they're all spread
by the large raspberry Avett and so we
caught we talked about raspberry mosaic
or the raspberry mosaic complex this
disease shows up very often in black
raspberries which are the most
susceptible in black raspberries mosaic
can cause tip necrosis or die Bach leaf
model and reduced vigor and yield in red
raspberries which are less susceptible
you may not see any symptoms unless
there are two or more viruses in the
plant two or more different viruses in
the same plant in this case you'll get
symptoms which resemble leaf model or
yellows and definitely a decline in
plant vigor and small or crumbly fruit
the disease is also present in wild
raspberries and often symptomless so
problems occur when a Fedora symptomless
hosts for example wild raspberries in
the nearby woods or bush and they bring
the virus to your healthy previously
healthy planting so one of the symptoms
of mosaic virus in black raspberries is
tip necrosis the growing tip blackens
and bends and and dries up and another
symptom of mosaic virus would be this
leaf model you can see the yellowish
spots on a darker background and this
type of symptom is more easy to to see
in the spring
the plant in this picture was not
confirmed as having a virus disease but
I wanted to show you it - as something
that could be a virus especially when
you see this leaf puckering oh there's
the arrow this that the deep kind of
puckering and in yellow modeling on the
new growth
so to control mosaic virus and these are
the virus diseases that are spread by
aphids you really need to prevent the
aphids from moving from infected plants
to non infected plants so first start
new raspberry plantings with
disease-free stalk that means grown in a
plant propagation program that uses
virus free nuclear stock and tests for
viruses throughout the program and
secondly it's important to isolate new
raspberry plantings from wild hosts you
should also separate black raspberries
from red raspberry plantings and this is
because red raspberries could have the
virus but not have symptoms and they're
more likely to spread the disease to
susceptible black raspberry plantings
nearby before you even know you have the
problem a minimum separation distance is
about 500 feet but a thousand feet or
more would be better these distances are
not foolproof but they are greater than
the distance an aphid is likely to fly
the problem is that if it's also spread
in prevailing winds and air currents and
so if possible you should think about
this when you're laying out a new
planting you may be surprised to know
that spraying insecticides to control
aphids is not really that useful this is
because Athens can spread the virus more
quickly than they would be killed by an
insecticide there are a few examples
when you might want to control aphids to
control viruses and I'll explain these
later finally many raspberry varieties
are resistant to the large raspberry a
Fed
this is particularly true of varieties
that are grown in the Pacific Northwest
and this a fedora Sisseton s-- is an
important way to control the spread of
virus diseases I tried to find some
examples of avian resistant cultivars
some of the older cultivars like Newberg
and Latham are definitely susceptible to
the large raspberry a fad and so these
are very susceptible to mosaic virus
whereas some other cultivars such as can
be revelry and Algonquian have this AG
gene where
comes from a parent plant breeders know
how to transfer or breed for varieties
that have this AG gene and are therefore
resistant to aphids and the virus but
unfortunately I couldn't find a lot of
information about this resistance in
some of our modern-day cultivars grown
in the Northeast
okay the next virus I'd like to talk
about and this is the one that I see the
most often is the tomato ringspot virus
it attacks red raspberries and
blackberries but not black raspberries
apparently and the symptoms can range
from from none to severe it's spread by
the degra nematode so it's really only a
problem in soils where diagur nematodes
are found in contrast to the mosaic
virus however which only occurs in the
raspberry genus rubus tomato ringspot
virus can be found in over 35 different
plant families including strawberries
apples peaches tomatoes and many
different broad-leaved weeds so we're
going to have a different approach to
controlling this virus in raspberries I
mentioned the symptoms are variable a
little unreliable for diagnosing this
virus it's generally associated with
decline crumbly fruit a loss in
productivity in infected plants early in
the onset of the disease you'll see
distinct ring spots or foliage patterns
on the primocane growth and these
symptoms are known as shock symptoms and
they show up early in the infection or
the year after infection and they may
not show up again in infected plants
and here's another picture of crumbly
fruit in this case it was caused by the
tomato ringspot virus like I said I see
this virus most often in Ontario because
the disease is spread by nematodes from
plant to plant it does spread fairly
slowly in the field infecting a few more
plants every year generally up and down
the row because you're spreading
nematodes with your tillage equipment
and and farm equipment and they're not
moving really quickly through a planting
it's just another symptom of of some of
the leaf leaf pattern that I saw last
summer on a field of Nova with tomato
ringspot virus and the crumbly fruit
that you've probably seen the fruit just
breaks breaks up when you pick it so to
control tomato ringspot virus first of
all you need to start with disease-free
planting stock but the virus could
already be on your farm in one of its
many weedy or alternate hosts so before
sit before planting raspberries you
should sample soil for nematodes and
control them if necessary and if dagger
nematodes were present in your soil
samples you would control them by soil
fumigation for example or or growing an
alternate crop for some years
I see tomato ringspot virus the most in
old in planting sites which were
previously an orchard or pasture I'm not
really sure why but these are likely to
have lots of the perennial broad-leaved
weeds that harbor tomato ringspot virus
so controlling weeds as well as the
nematodes can help reduce the incidence
and spread of tomato ringspot virus
now the third virus is the raspberry
bushy dwarf virus and the vector for
this is pollen from infected plants so
this can be a very difficult virus to
control it only attacks raspberries the
symptoms again vary with the cultivar in
the season and plants may or may not
show symptoms each year but it is a
serious virus because it causes crumbly
berry in some cultivars and it's
associates associated with a decline in
productivity these are some of the leaf
symptoms we see in the spring with
raspberry bushes or virus for years I've
missed diagnosed this as herbicide
damage it does look quite a lot like
herbicide injury this is another picture
of raspberry bushes were fond the
variety Qualicum this irregular
bleaching is less consistent with
herbicide injury this is a field of
primal keen fruiting varieties in the
spring
both are infected with the raspberry
bushy Dorf virus but the variety autumn
britain on the Left shows much more
distinct symptoms than the variety
Caroline which is on the right
as I said it's very difficult to control
raspberry bushi door virus but again you
should also start always start your
plantings with disease-free planting
stock if you do see symptoms of this
virus or any of the other virus diseases
you should rogue out those plants if
possible remove the infected plants and
plants on either side there's very few
resistant cultivars to raspberry bushes
or virus the variety Chilcotin
apparently is resistant this is a
variety that's grown mostly in the
Pacific Northwest it's not very winter
hardy in Ontario and there are strains
of the raspberry bushes or virus
apparently which can break through the
genetic resistance of these raspberries
now it's always a little difficult to
diagnose virus diseases so I'm going to
spend a bit of time on that topic first
of all there's a lot of symptoms that
can look like viruses so before you can
be sure that you have a virus or before
you even test for viruses you should
consider some of these other
possibilities for example past herbicide
applications would be good to know you
should check out the nutritional status
of your crop with leaf and soil analysis
and scout for other insects and diseases
this symptom is caused by herbicide from
glyphosate or roundup you've probably
seen it in raspberries the symptoms show
up the year after the roundup was
applied or drifted on to the crop but
the chlorosis and the yellowing and the
small stunted leaves could be mistaken
for virus diseases
potato leafhopper can cause a leaf model
or yellowing or leaf curl particularly
on the new growth in this case a crop
Scout should find evidence of leaf
hoppers on the lower leaf surface
tarnished plant bugs occasionally
damaged the drupelets when the fruit is
sizing in the fruit can be deformed or
poor pollination especially in the
greenhouse can result in crumbly or
deformed fruit I've seen crumbly berry
associated with too low of a soil pH or
inadequate crop crop nutrition when some
varieties are just weak necked and tend
to break up a little more easily than
others but if crumbly fruit predominates
on a few plants in your planting and
more plants are affected every year you
should have samples tested for virus
diseases so how do you diagnose a virus
disease well you need to use the
services of a lab that has green house
or lab facilities there's two
characteristic tests that are done to
test for viruses most diagnostic labs
will carry ELISA test kits for the
common virus diseases when you use
anna-lysa tests you need one test for
each known virus and what happens is the
virus from the infected tissue to put it
very simply and probably not quite
accurately the virus from infected
tissue reacts in the presence of
antibodies and added enzymes which are
which are put in these little plates in
the little Eliza plates on your left
more recently PCR techniques or
polymerase chain reaction techniques are
used to identify specific viruses or
groups of viruses by their genetic
material these tests are fairly
expensive and they're not done at many
labs PCR tests though can be used to
detect families or groups of viruses if
you know the genetic code but my whole
point is really to identify and confirm
a virus disease you need a diagnostic
lab that is equipped to diagnose the
common diseases of brambles
so here's a slide to show some of the
labs you could consider depending which
country you're in
to send some samples for disease
diagnosis or confirmation of a virus
disease you should pick a lab and then
call first to get the price list to find
out what what it's going to cost what
viruses these labs can test for egg dia
is a very good lab I believe it's in
Indiana in the USA it's well equipped to
diagnose virus diseases and the website
for egg dia has good information about
how viruses are diagnosed and they have
a price list up there two other labs you
might consider are if you're in Ontario
the pest diagnostic clinic at the
University of Guelph or Ann New York the
plant disease diagnostic clinic like I
said it's best to call ahead find out
what virus kits they have on hand and it
does get very difficult to ship
plant samples across the border so if
you're in Canada you need to use a lab
in Canada and the same in the States use
an American lab but whatever lab you use
choose fresh samples of plant tissue
with symptoms and remember that viruses
are easiest to detect in the spring
because the concentration or a titer of
the virus in the tissue is highest then
and at other times of the year you may
be more likely to get false negative
results and you should test again the
next year okay so my last few slides
have to do with controlling virus
diseases but really what you're trying
to do is prevent virus diseases from
getting onto your farm and I think I've
said this already a couple of times one
of the most important things is to start
with clean planting stalk don't grow
your own raspberries even though it may
seem like an economical option at the
time a professional plant propagator
will use parent material that has been
freed from viruses usually through a
combination of heat treatment and tissue
culture from the growing tip of the
plant this is the screen house analyst
Kurt were a nuclear stalk for on
Theriault plant growers is produced you
can see several features on this
building which are designed to keep
virus vectors like aphids away they're
screened vents double air locked
entrance and there's no weeds around the
edges of this screen house
certified practices for nursery
production include growing plants in
fumigated or nematode free soil
isolation from wild hosts and regular
scouting and pest control so your
nursery growers plant growers are going
to a lot of extra steps to make sure
that the risk of viruses is very low in
their fields the second thing you should
do is try to isolate raspberry plantings
from virus sources now that I know this
isn't always practical but it should be
in the back of your mind and isolation
slows the movement of aphids from
infested plantings to new plantings and
this is really important for controlling
mosaic viruses so a separation from wild
brambles older plantings and separating
red raspberries from blackberries is a
rule of thumb the third thing is to
return the routinely identify and remove
infected plants this is known as rogen
you would scout for symptoms and remove
infected plants maybe twice a year now
this strategy can be effective when less
than five to ten percent of the plants
are infected otherwise if more than that
is infected I guess you should remove
the whole planting when it's no longer
making money for you now the one time
you might control aphids is before
removing these infected plants from your
planting because a spray for a if it's
to kill the aphids before you pull out
the plant will help prevent these aphids
from flying on to new uninfected plants
I already talked a bit about weed
control and nematode control as a
strategy for controlling tomato ringspot
virus just remember that many
broad-leaved weeds are sources for this
virus and that degra nematodes have many
hosts and finally I promised to talk a
tiny bit about a food control I
mentioned it's not feasible to prevent
virus infection into new fields
generally by controlling aphids you
would have to spray far too frequently
and aphids can quickly transmit the
disease to two
a raspberry plant so spraying routinely
for aphids is something a plant
propagator does but it's not really
something that's practical on a field
scale however there are a couple of
times when controlling aphids might be
useful and this would be if you have an
infested planting and you want to reduce
the rate of spread within that planting
and the other is when you're removing
plants as you can see the references and
published literature on virus diseases
of raspberry small fruit is somewhat
dated these are some of the sources I
used when I was compiling this
presentation but our our knowledge of
virus diseases is changing especially in
the last decade and new techniques are
being developed for diagnosing virus
diseases I'm pretty sure that we all are
going to know a lot more about virus
diseases in the future and and in the
years to come thank you
thanks Pam there is one question from
Tom Stevenson about potato leafhopper
and whether that's a concern for
vectoring bramble virus
it would not be a common vector of
bramble viruses that we know having said
that there are some other virus like
diseases which I didn't discuss known as
phyto planned so it's not something I
would be extremely concerned about from
that perspective all right thank you but
I do have a caveat there I do have a
caveat in that our knowledge about the
types of virus diseases and Fido plans
is is changing a lot a few people are
working very hard in this field and
they're always discovering new new virus
diseases okay great thank you and Marvin
has a question about the importance of
separating black and red raspberries and
new plantings that are established with
virus indexed plants
so the assumption then is that you don't
have virus in your in your plantings and
so do you need to separate them and you
know to tell you the truth I don't see a
lot of separation between red and black
raspberries but I think if there's a
chance that your red raspberries are
going to get mosaic virus from a feds
from the woods or the bush or a lot of
wild brambles nearby then the the theory
would be if you separated those from
your blacks you would reduce the spread
to the black raspberries but the black
raspberries are going to be close to
those wild sources too so it's a good
point Marvin and I think it's one of
those motherhood recommendations that
you would do if you could but you might
not always do okay I like that I've
never heard that before but I like that
description
yeah does anyone else have any questions
for Pam well she's just finishing with
the virus disease no other questions so
I know some folks don't like to type so
much but I let you keep throwing up some
questions while I change our
presentations and Pam will be at the
we'll be still here for the remainder of
this so if you have if you do think of
something don't hesitate to just take
your time and type it in there and and
that would be great and now I'm going to
introduce our second speaker who is dr.
Carrick Cox dr. Cox has a program of
tree fruit and berry research and
extension at Cornell University's New
York State Agricultural Experiment
Station in Geneva dr. Cox's program
focuses on the chemical management of
fungal diseases of Apple stone fruit and
berries with specific emphasis on the
biology ecology mechanisms and
prevalence prevalence excuse me a
fungicide resistance in brown rot and
apple scab but he has been instrumental
helping me certainly and others in the
extension field in New York
very crop diseases and so I will turn
off my speaker now and turn it over to
you Carrick and Pam thank you very much
you
you
you
root diseases but I think we'll get to
the crux of it
you
[ __ ] I'm going to go over a couple of
items
Kerrick this is Laura I'm sorry to
interrupt but I think we're having a
problem with your audio hold on one
second
carick ok I'm sorry this is Laura and we
are having pretty some I think pretty
severe where I'm not hearing you at all
hardly and other folks are saying that
the audio is cutting in and out what if
I do
high volume there you know and Boop's
do you have your headset on ok now your
I'm hearing you now are you did you put
your hands-free the little rock on yeah
you can see because it's constantly
flickering hey yeah it wasn't and now it
is on and now I do hear you so hopefully
all right why don't we click there's a
slight lag yeah why don't we move back
to the beginning of your presentation
and I I'm sorry about that I couldn't
get your attention you were on a roll
and I couldn't hear you at all but I'm
gonna I'm gonna stop out and maybe now
I'm not hearing you again yep all right
there you go all right hopefully I don't
know why it's cutting out on us we have
had such good luck so far
all right let's see how we're doing now
looks like I'm flickering so let's go
ahead I didn't say anything too terribly
important at this point we'll move on to
the talk proper alright I'll give a
little bit of information about
understanding diseases of brambles and
then I'll talk about brembo root
diseases and management and then look at
root diseases in 2009 and some of the
issues that seem to be involved with a
small fruit decline this year and what
to do about diseases and root decline in
2010 given our seasonal situations of
course this talk is very much here so to
the northeastern United States and of
course New York where we've had some
very interesting weather but I I think
some of those situations would also
apply to
obviously since we share a lot of the
same overall weather conditions
Oh for
section is what are the difficulties
fruit diseases present bramble producers
in New York let's look at this sometimes
they can be very frustrating and
established operations the reason why is
that the most effective management
practices are preventive they occur
prior to planting so if they're getting
them in you're already established
planting this becomes a very big
headache for producers and even thus
extension people
often times they become apparent after
the planting established you've gone
several years and all of a sudden they
are beginning to show up three
unfortunately the post planting
management practices when you're in
these situations are less effective and
they seem to only really slow the spread
and unfortunately there is very little
one can do to cure the affected plants
when the problem becomes fairly apparent
to both you and any extension person
coming to visit your site as well but
also very frustrating to identifying
diagnose for a lot of the same reasons
unfortunately these pathogens are in our
soil borne protecting and hidden in the
soil just as Pam mentioned with viruses
these are things we're not going to be
able to see very well and it's not so
much the fact that they are small or
microscopic some of them very much so
are is that they are hidden from view
and we don't see them until they've
already gone so far that there is a
point of no return for action in terms
of being a grower also the diagnostic
symptoms are below ground which prevents
recognition during a time when you might
be able to take action to save the
planting and of course once the plan is
dead it becomes a fungal decay
free-for-all preventing you or myself or
any other person visiting your farm from
determining what actually you is the
cause
so you key is to catch them early but
often times it's impossible for you to
find them early yeah the one good factor
in all this is that the most common root
diseases affect all berry crops and
their management practices are similar
so even if you're not here specifically
for raspberries a lot of the same stuff
we're talking about will apply to all
small fruit diseases or if you have a
diversified planting as I imagine many
of you might a lot of what we'll talk
about here will be very applicable in
all situations
let's look I'd like to do a little bit
of the presentation on winter injury
because in many cases winter injury can
mimic or look like a root disease
problem and be responsible for decline
however and brambles winter injury is a
little different than in some of the
other small fruits what usually occurs
is winter injury usually results from
spring phrases in March and it usually
kills the buds only and it's less so due
to winter temperatures overall being
just a cold temperature you really need
many days of lower than 20 degrees
Fahrenheit before you're actually going
to start killing prime Akane's
so for the most part when you see winter
injury it may not necessarily be a root
problem but it may in fact look like a
root decline one of the things that I've
read that may cause trouble is if you do
a lot of permanent mulching it could
delay plant hardening and then there's a
separate winter injury problems but
that's not the test this early always be
concerned about of course in the case of
winter injury any time a plant becomes
stress from disease including root
diseases or other any body at factors
like nutrition your plants is gonna be
more predisposed to winter injuries so
anytime a plant gets stressed prior to
going dormant you've just increased that
chance of actually getting damaged to
winter injury in this case that type of
damage in the form
by McCain damage would be much more
troublesome consequences what will end
up happening is the plant will look
produced vigour productivity the four
canes will be the most heavily
influenced they may not they may break
but they may begin to wilt and you can
get death but it's very variety of
specific with very little specific
information on the varieties that are
most impacted by winter injury
diagnostic symptoms in this case as with
other bramble winter injury symptoms
another small fruit the whole plant may
die but in the case of raspberries and
brambles what ends up happening is the
temperatures warm before canes will
appear to be wilt while the prima canes
remain healthy why this is is that the
buds on the Prima canes are seemed to be
the most affected by the winter injury
so when they burst into flora canes
they'll begin to wilt due to damaged
vascular connections so what one can see
in these very small pictures one for my
own stuff
very diagnostic keys that you'll see a
lot of the newer flora canes looking for
rather weakened and injured while the
prima canes themselves look fairly good
let's see if I can change the color to
something
see that they are dying at the tips and
all along that row while the prime
mccain's themselves look quite fine
let's skip over to slide pains
to the ground but like I spend before
broads or the primary source of affected
material when it comes to winter injury
but don't let it completely confuse you
one thing that is interesting about
winter injury is that somewhat
diagnostic the plants will continue or
send up new promo canes that stay
healthy however if your plants are
actually suffering from a root disease
the plants will continue declining
throughout the season as will be more
evident when we get right down into the
diseases themselves let's look at one
here Phytophthora root rot one of the
more prevalent diseases in small fruit
and that for brambles as well it's a
chronic pathogen which means it
basically lives as an underwater
organism it when it's dried out it's
simply just surviving that's why it
likes wet soils and low-lying areas
these things are all very familiar with
one of the other interesting features of
Phytophthora is that it prefers cool
temperatures and cool weather which can
be a problem if we have cool springs and
cool summers let's look at the symptom
so what will happen is you'll get some
stunting and chlorosis at the end to see
the chlorosis here of course it didn't
draw anything ah there it goes some of
the chlorosis just simply meaning a
yellow spot and of course wilt and death
of plants in patches as the soil begins
to warm you can see there's a nice patch
of really wilting and dying plants
so in order to diagnose a raspberry
let's say you're seeing Wilton death and
patches and you're planting you want to
see whether or not it's Phytophthora or
or something completely different
take the wilting plant don't pick a dead
one like I said once they're dead it
becomes a fungal free-for-all and you
may not be able to tell what's actually
happening dig it up remove the soil from
the root system if you have four Toffler
you'll notice that many of the fine
roots and lateral roots will have rotted
away it won't be a nice you won't have
all the nice bushy fine root material
cut through the crown in the large roots
now what you'll see if it's completely
white underneath you know you're you're
gonna be fine like this piece here
however if you begin to see a reddish
chocolate brown pick portion with a
sharply delineated white area you will
begin to note that that is very suspect
to Phytophthora you'll get these
chocolate red brown sections but it'll
be sharply delineated with a white a
slightly white section like right there
at that margin so that's very indicative
of Phytophthora in that case you might
suspect that you're planting had a fight
off the problem and that those patches
of dying plants was indeed due to that
of course wet spots and low-lying areas
are also going to be dead giveaways as
well or suggestions one thing to
consider is that once your plant gets
killed by Phytophthora all the
Phytophthora infected propagules are
going to hang out in that dead tissue
and some of them will get into the soil
and remain dormant until you have those
temperatures of cool weather and water
and will cause infections in later
seasons so if you had was planting that
was killed or destroyed by Phytophthora
and then you remove the plants bear in
mind that those pools are still going to
be waiting for you the next time you
replant and they can last for quite some
time unfortunately management um
obviously select a site with a rail
train soil use raised beds if possible
this isn't something I always see in
raspberry production but if it was
possible it would be something that
would help
and obviously since it's on aquatic
pathogen as much irrigation artificial
as you can avoid would be great so if
you could minimize the water that is the
key to managing fatah flora root rot at
least culturally of course select an
appropriate variety there are
differences in resistance among
raspberry varieties however they are not
often well known in the movie best serve
by looking in your nursery catalog for
which varieties claimed to have some
form of resistance
well larger somaye newt it may be and
picking one like that if you think you
have a planting with a lot of low-lying
spots and potential wet spots or a field
that's historically more wet chemical
there are things you can do chemically
to manage Phytophthora however these are
only gonna work with good cultural
management practices if you're trying to
grow these things hydroponically it
won't matter how much fungicide you
spray Phytophthora if it's present will
be will still overwhelm the system one
of the materials is called methane oxen
it's called red mole gold usually
involves an autumn soil application
however there is a strong propensity for
fungicide resistance development to this
however there are some newer softer
materials that are actually very
effective against by tatra a Liette pro
fight foster all these are phosphorous
acid biopesticides
and these you can apply an early spring
in late summer to the foliage and they
do do a good job as an example there
were used for a while to manage sudden
oak death in California with aerial
applications and fairly effectively so
these are actually a good alternative to
the hard core fungicide if you have a
photographer problem now I'd like to
change gears and move to the next
disease that one can find in brambles in
our region verticillium wilt
it's a vascular disease meaning that it
ruins the vascular tissue and is going
to end up causing a wilt whenever the
vascular tissue is in hampered you can
expect that plants will begin the wilt
it's a pathogen on many hosts including
a lot of weeds and vegetables
fortunately it's the black raspberries
that are usually most heavily impacted
by
disease and according to a lot of
literature I've seen the red and the
purple appear as a whole to be less
susceptible to the problem but I would
not exclude them from having the
possibility of getting the disease
um the fortunate thing is this has some
ground symptoms and stuff to look for
this one is easy to identify and not
only brambles but other small fruit
crops as well and of course it when it
disrupts vascular function it's kind of
like not giving the plant enough water
it will be stunted wilt and you can kill
or verticillium can kill the plant
symptoms and diagnosis what will end up
happening first is the young canes oh
well first from the base to the tips
petioles will remain attached and the
older leaves will look scorched you can
see some of the older leaves down here
at the base of this cane in particular
they are sort of crispy torn up and
messed up however some of the younger
leaves at the top are you can still see
our green so that's one thing to look
for of course there's a more severe
situation where everything is scorched
at the bottom all the older leaves are
pretty much ruined they almost look
burnt one thing that you can also find
in cases of severely infected canes
you'll see blueish spots you might
notice that this spot is a little pale
brown or something like that but this
area here is a little more blue these
bluish indications may be an indication
of verticillium infection this isn't
necessarily the best picture of it and
unfortunately black raspberries have
bluish cast to their cane which makes it
kind of tricky but look for spots and
there are better pictures not very few
on the internet show this situation very
carefully yeah I've got better in
strawberry but this can be something to
look for management what can you do
about verticillium wilt unfortunately
this is a difficult one the pathogen can
survive in soils after weeds and
vegetables for many years it makes a
resistant structure called a sclerotia
and can hide out in the soil waiting for
you to plant after purchasing a tomato a
field planet - tomato eggplant peppers
whatever
if you plant after many of these hosts
there is a possibility that you could
get verticillium wilt of course it may
not always be practical to wait three
years but it is something to consider if
you have a planting declining and it was
after one of these things putting things
like stone fruit trees which are rather
strange but may be present in a
diversified farm in the region so
something to watch out for as Pam
mentioned on many instances it's very
important to use verticillium free
planting stock if your planting stock
has the little blue splotches throughout
on your black raspberries it's maybe you
not want to use that one ever consider
that there could be a problem with it
before planting it
unfortunately there's no complete
resistance not like flat-out immunity as
I mentioned earlier the red and purple
raspberries appear to be less
susceptible to disease so if you're
coming in after one of these other crops
you may want to consider a red or a
purple raspberry variety you can
fumigate but fumigation has become
impractical in recent years due to cost
and many of the legislation legislative
guidelines under which it must occur
it's not something that's done that
often and it's something I believe that
we should get away for environment away
from doing for environmental concerns
let's hook briefly about krungel it's
one of the other diseases that one may
find
it's a vascular tumor disease so
basically what's happening in this case
is a soil borne bacterial pathogen is
causing tumor like growths on a root
system again it will disrupt the
vascular function causing the plants to
appear to wilt
can I get stunting wilting they're not
going to be as productive and
unfortunately if you get one of these it
will predispose you for a winter injury
because the things occur at the crown
and the type of winter injury occurring
at the crown is not something that one
wishes to have fortunately these are
very early sometimes fairly easy to find
if they actually occur at the crown
here's two pictures from the very
diagnostic key in order to find or
determine whether you have this problem
look at the base of the Canes and crowns
if you and of course dig up a root
system if you don't see anything but
what will happen is on the lower crowns
and stems and roots won't find these
tumor like growths highlight that one
it's kind of a dark color they
eventually will get old and the bacteria
will be released as they decay and enter
into the soil again which causes
problems so in these instances there are
your little tumor like growths and of
course that's the the cause of the
problem yes as I mentioned before
they will disintegrate sometimes after
they are formed over the course of
heading into dormancy and they release
the bacteria into the soil another thing
to keep in mind is this is a common
disease problem in stone fruit and
especially grapes in this region crown
gall and in grapes is fairly prevalent
and if you're planting in land after one
of these two situations there's always a
possibility that you could be planting
in the soils that have this bacteria
it's management obviously if you see
planting stock with goals or odd growths
on the roots or crowns don't don't use
it by all means also take care after
planting after stone for another grapes
if you're finding old root systems with
galls and bumps on it you might want to
consider planting somewhere else most
importantly avoid practices that injure
the crown and roots so what this
bacterium does is it's in the soil in
any injury near the crown and roots that
occurs in contact with the soil and if
the bacterium was present can be the
site of the gall formation
hence in that one picture we showed a
while back the raspberry crown there was
probably some sort of injury that caused
the bacteria to infect and begin it's
tumors as the opposite situation is
possible even winter injury and insects
can wound sufficiently to cause an
infection for the bacterium so even a
little bit of wind your injury and
insect pressure if it's too high can
predispose you to this disease if you
have soil with the bacterium
unfortunately with crown gall there's
not much you can do chemically so you
just have to be very careful and how you
set up your plantings and the planting
stock you use so at this point I'd like
to quickly talk a little bit about root
diseases 2009 or some of the things that
we had run into or possible problems
questions being is what role did root
diseases playing plant decline in the
2009 season it didn't look like many of
you experienced this thank goodness but
there was a lot of it at diversified
planting so I thought it pertinent to
address and what can we do to prepare
for root diseases and plant decline in
2007 do they commonly index for crown
crown gall and small fruit nurseries I
have no idea I think it's a fairly rare
disease and you don't see it that much
however I think that any nursery that
saw the diagnostic symptoms of it
wouldn't grow it it's in the soil much
less so in the plants and so the plants
would likely be clean unless they were
bringing him out of contaminated soil
and I imagine that they would spot and
not not even sell it so I don't know if
they specifically do it but I imagine by
just a common quality practices they
would see it and remove it
2009 um I got a lot of reports of small
fruit decline especially in strawberries
but summon brambles and/or raspberries
as well
unfortunately these all's happened in
the late season and in many cases
decline progressed to a point where it
was difficult to confirm root disease
however we did find several indications
of verticillium wilt and fight author
and of course winter injury so that was
somewhat surprising in the last three
years of my appointment when you've seen
very few instances of this in 2009 was
especially a bad year for becoming aware
of these problems obviously the spring
was fairly dry and cool not not too
unusual however the June July months was
really wet a lot of rain many inches of
rainfall and the temperatures were cool
as I've noted for monitoring weather for
other diseases it was an extremely cold
summer and many of you probably realized
this as well if you have cold conditions
and a lot of water it might have made a
very favorable situation for
Phytophthora and it may be that in many
cases
um yes according I'll maybe I'll answer
that question later almost done um in
many instances if you have cool
conditions and wetter a lot of wetness
you will run into problems with
Phytophthora and this may explain what
we've had happen so what can we do to
prepare the conditions were very
favorable for root disease in 2009 there
could be a lot of high levels of
inoculum even if you didn't have any
root disease decline last year the
situation may be prepped for having
enough inoculum such that if the
conditions exist you could get a root
disease problem if you thought you had
decline in 2009 or had a lot of wet
spots or maybe some unthrifty plants and
it was in a wet spot some of those
situations that would be conducive for
Phytophthora you may want to consider
putting on a spring application of a
phosphorous acid product as a
preventative measure for managing
Phytophthora and potentially affected
fields if you get a head start on it you
will be able to potentially manage it if
the disease begins to show up later in
the season and you can finally see it
without digging it up it's usually too
late to do anything about it so this
year may be pertinent to use a
preventative application of a Fozzy acid
product if you're have fields in which
would or could develop life at our
problem low-lying wet fields and oral
fields with a lot of wet spots and you
went through last 2009 even without a
problem um also there could be increased
winter injury in 2010 even if your
raspberries had a lot of foliar diseases
towards the end of the season you know
even things like leaf spots of rust and
a little bit of anthracnose this may
have predisposed you for winter injury
as you enter dormancy what you want to
do is make sure that your plantings are
well insulated in in the spring Scout
frequently fir the signs of declining
plants you could use this handout to
determine whether or not you have a
winter injury issue or potentially a
root disease problem if you can
recognize the cause of this early you
can take action
to get rid of the losses I mean many of
the diseases you can't do much about
such as verticillium and crown gall but
these are less likely to have simply
emerged over the course of two ceases
what this would allow you to get a
handle on things such as fight off
alright looks like we already have a
question if a prime McCain is mowed down
and the winter and the Canes get broken
by the mower will this increase
susceptibility crown gall I would I
would imagine so if the bacterium is
present in the soil mowing would be an
excellent way to injure your canes to
provide a source of infection for the
crown ball bacterium however if you been
mowing for many years and have never
seen it then it is likely the crown gall
bacterium is not in your soil other
question Carrick I was wondering if you
had any opinion about actinovate as a
preventive approach to verticillium I've
used actinovate and other cropping
systems particularly on tree fruit and
haven't had any I haven't had a
considerable measurable success in
getting it to manage diseases that are
also fungi um I don't know I I'm very
hesitant to recommend any fungicide use
for verticillium wilt because usually
the pathogens in the soil and the
actinovate is bringing on the foliage I
mean you could in theory drench it if it
isn't co-ordinates with a label but I
imagine the you know getting it through
the soil to the plant to the site where
the verticillium would be is is kind of
a stretch with any fungicide including a
actinovate which is a soft product oh
the motive acts like a no let's see if
some of these others came Phytophthora
root rot kill a plant within one season
I would imagine if it got going you
could lose an entire plant it will look
wilted on Thrifty it may or may not die
depends on how robust your planting is
if it's a long established planting it
may be able to outlast it however the
fight off ler is going to be there
waiting for it next season mode of
action yeah no I was just trying to yeah
the motive action of the phosphorous
acid products motive action for the
phosphorous acid products involves the
phosphide ion is actually directly
lethal to the Phytophthora pathogen now
there's been a lot of work to look at
the phosphorous acid the phosphite ions
effect on other fungi it doesn't appear
to have a strong of effect the the
Phytophthora is not actually a fungus
it is a aquatic organism in an entirely
different Kingdom when it seems to be
very susceptible to the phosphide Island
now a product like a Liette has to go
through several breakdown steps in the
soil while the newer phosphorous acid
products can kind of skip the middleman
of breakdown and go straight through the
ion in the ion becoming available it
seems to be what damages the
Phytophthora okay Tom Stephenson has a
question about whether or not nurseries
commonly index for crown gall I imagine
that's something that they're aware of
and would see but I don't know if they
specifically have an indexing program
for it I imagine it would be something
that would show up as a catch-all I mean
it's very obvious I doubt they would
think oh no my raspberry has
nitrogen-fixing root nodules that's
probably fine I imagine that's something
that would flag very easily in a
quality-control situation and it's
mostly in the soil not necess you know
it can get in the plants but I mentioned
they're growing their plants and very
clean soil so it's unless it was really
sloppy operation I imagine they would
catch that but I don't know of any they
have a specific crown crown gall
indexing program okay and then Alan
Baker has a question about fall red
raspberries that bloomed and set fruit
buds but in mid-october at a killing
freeze and do you have any idea if that
will have any effect on the seasons
production um well if the buds here
I don't know that's that's a good
question it may if Marvin
so I guess Marvin's microphones and
probably not on but
I don't know I mean that was Alan those
must be like a heritage a pre McCain
berry right I mean a killing freezes is
not good but I think the quick now
here's the parasitizing okay yeah should
see we think I would have yes guys hard
to say should be a prosecution
setbacks are separation of crops if it's
a mixed vegetable and very farm
uh-huh yeah I would keep my obviously
the peppers seem to be the the poster
child for verticillium well and III
think if as long as you don't plant them
immediately after peppers or any of
those other events or tomato I think
you're probably be fine in terms of
worrying about them now I ever
Phytophthora can getting all those as
well if you have my frittata problem in
a field then you're planning next to it
with your raspberries that could be an
issue which you'd want to do is make
sure that water doesn't drain from the
infected field to the field of your
raspberries a water will carry the
Phytophthora so in that case that would
be the if you can separate them by water
source you can eliminate a lot of the
disease problems or if you don't plant
in the same area where you've had a
problem in a vegetable plant it and we
usually recommend like a three year
rotational separation using you know an
unrelated crops or a cover crop or
something is that that isn't that isn't
the blood is on the verticillium
recommends for a many places yes
don't wait three years even after stones
root and certain weed crops if you have
a heavy weed infestation it can carry
verticillium as well like pigweed horse
nettle some of those others
them isn't there so there's a couple
more yeah he book typing in thanks poke
over again how much is too much well
well if you're starting to see flooding
or if you can pick up the soil and
you're getting a lot of moisture on your
hands and that may be too much however
if your plants are wilting from drought
you need to irrigate them testing former
carick did we lose you know I'm here I'm
just looking at Jeff's question should
we test pond waters used for irrigation
for fight ah throw uh I I don't know if
anyone does that necessarily I don't
know if you'll you'll see it in there so
much unless you have a problem with
fight off that other areas in your
operation I don't think it would
necessarily be a good use of your time
necessarily to try to test that way the
best use of time would be to see
declining plants and quickly pull them
up look and see if there's a problem or
take a healthy plant that's near your
irrigation and make sure it doesn't have
those nice chocolate areas would do any
aid up against white tissue use it extra
plant is an indicator if as you folks
think of a couple more questions for dr.
Cox and Thank You Carrick so much that
was a great presentation and it but
please there's a little bit more time
that if you do think of some questions
let's let's lay them out there I have a
couple of more poll questions that I'd
like to introduce just quickly
and I'm gonna open it up and ask
everybody to please vote there's thirty
four of us logged on and if you're a
grower I'd love it if you could to join
us and armed with the handout of this
presentation knowledge of my own
operation and abundant free time I yeah
that's right you could just could
probably determine the cause of a
bramble decline could definitely
determine the cause and of decline
probably couldn't determine the cause
and still couldn't identify the cause
nor what to do about it we'd love to get
some feedback from you and that handout
that dr. Cox mentioned is available you
can download it on to your computer and
we'll give folks a little bit of time we
I think we had about twenty growers or
22 growers that were present I'd love to
see that many folks voting
and Pam Fisher is still with us so if
anybody has any virus questions please
type those in we can address them now as
well got about 17 people a couple more
folks maybe if they could vote I guess
not so I'm going to close this poll and
then I have one other hold on I just get
a locked in here
one other pod to pull pull to ask you
and hopefully people can see this I'll
try to make it bigger
we'll see if people thought this was
helpful to the manda management the
presentation helpful to your management
of bramble viruses on your farm
and if we could get about 17 or 18
people to vote that would be great
wonderful thank you guys very much for
participating in this I want to thank
unless open there might be somebody else
oh there is another question for Pam why
is puckering of leaves more associated
with viruses versus other disease
diseases Pam or possibly even Carrick
maybe you guys could weigh in on that
question
they're thinking well go ahead Pam if
you want I I mean it's probably killing
some of the faster growing cells some
cells remain growing while the younger
ones are being killed off and causes
they miss shapen development on Aries
and the leaves I mean that's what
viruses do they kill cells so maybe
somewhere more impact another Pam he
have an idea
I don't know we're not hearing her
Bunge I rot things so they don't
necessarily cause stunted individual
cell growth hope something's happening
yeah that was me sorry I didn't have my
mic on yeah I think if you're trying to
compare them to leaf diseases then there
are things that cause puckering like
cold temperature damage or mechanical
damage that just makes the leaf grow
more quickly in some parts than others
but of the other fungal diseases that
attack raspberries I don't think they
work that way
alright that was like those are great
answers to that question I was a little
trickier but I want to encourage if you
do have any other questions now's the
time I'm going to draw your attention
one more time to these handouts that you
can upload onto your own computer in the
file share box and I think this
concludes our ramble disease management
webinar but I want to draw your
attention to our final bramble and the
entire Cornell berry Series berry
webinar series will be held on Wednesday
February 17th it's the bramble insect
management webinar we have dr. Don
Johnson from the university of arkansas
talking to us as well as dr. Hannah
Barak from North Carolina State
University and they were very happy to
have them so I really appreciate
everybody logging on I do want to just
encourage you if folks if you do not get
the email from me the day before please
don't hesitate to either call me or
email me and I'll make sure it gets sent
the connection information gets sent
something is happening in the last
couple of rounds with the bulk email to
people some people are not getting that
and I you know mark it on your calendar
and if you don't see it don't hesitate
to contact me and I'll send it
individually to you but I appreciate
again our speakers time and expertise
and thank you all for logging on take
care all right bye
you
you
you